So I'm here with Cameron Pittman, who
is a course developer here at Udacity.
He's going to talk to us
a little bit about metacognition.
So thank you for talking to us today.
>> Yeah, happy to be here.
>> So the first thing I want to ask is,
the reason why I'm talking to Cameron
about metacognition is that Udacity has
started a new type of
debate class they call R&R.
And can you tell us a little
bit about what that is?
>> Sure, R&R is not a replacement for
the classroom.
It's just another way
to engage students.
Our classes are essentially a series of,
as you guys probably well know, videos,
questions, problems, projects,
and some short readings.
And that's actually where we're
extending the classroom here with R&R.
R&R is actually, I think it stands for
reading and reflection.
It's essentially a set of
topics online or blog posts or
news articles or any kind of writings
online that are relevant to the course.
And what we simply do is ask
students to read them and
then reflect in the forums.
It's just another way of
trying to engage students and
introducing them to material
that's out in the world.
>> So it's worth noting that when they
started the R&R way of doing classes
here at Udacity I didn't know about it.
And they did it in parallel
to me designing this class.
And so this R&R approach is very
much what we do in this class where
it's all about readings and going out
and finding your own resources and
reflecting on them and
sharing them with classmates.
But something I'd ask for both these
students in this class as well as for
general understanding of the way this
is used, is this for everybody, or
is this a kind of approach
that's specifically for
people who don't learn
from traditional methods,
that don't like to learn from lectures,
that they need an alternate way?
Or is this the better way to learn for
everybody?
>> I would never couch something
as a better way to learn for
everybody because everybody
learns differently.
There are different modes of learning.
Some people learn better visually,
auditorially, or in-discussionally.
Okay, that's not a word.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But anyways, so this is just another
way of introducing students to material,
that they wouldn't normally see.
And I think this is a great method,
because as a developer, which is what
we're training people to become, you
have to be up to date with current news.
You have to be up to date with the
current thoughts on whatever technology
it is you're working with.
And R&R is just a great
way to reflect that.
So, its not replacing anything and
I don't think its necessarily
a better way to learn.
It's just another way of introducing
students to the world around them.
I like it a lot because it doesn't
just teach you the content
that you're learning about.
It doesn't teach you how to design
a form or how to write a line of code.
But it also teaches you that in the
future when you encounter a problem that
you don't know how to solve,
how would you go out and solve it?
And that's almost more important.
It's one thing to teach
someone something but
it's something else to teach them
how to solve their future problems.
>> And not to mention it also introduces
students to developer communities.
You start meeting other people or seeing
other people who are interested in
the same technologies and it gives
students a chance to get involved.
>> Yeah, absolutely.
So since this is an Ed Tech class
though, one question I would have is,
is technology, aside from us being in
computer science, so let's imagine for
a second we're doing R&R
in an English class or
something like that, how does
technology actually help with this?
Is it a core part of the R&R process, or
is it just that, because we're teaching
computer science here at Udacity we
tend to use technology along with this.
>> Well, I think technology in this case
is just a better way to do paperwork.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> You know,
you could easily do this in the class.
Millions of teachers probably have.
You assign a reading to your students,
you get them to read.
And that's essentially
all we're doing here.
And technology just makes it easier.
It's not necessarily better or worse,
it's just easier and
more accessible to students.
>> Yeah, it sounds like it introduces
a more rapid feedback cycle because
instead of having to go to the library,
find an encyclopedia,
read about it, go home and
realize I read the wrong thing,
I can go through that cycle in
a minute instead of in a day.
So it really let's them go
through that more often.
So if we have any students in the class
who want to apply an approach like this,
an R&R style approach, or an approach
that really fosters metacognition in
their project that they develop for this
class, do you have any suggestions for
what they should think about
while they're doing it?
>> Yeah, sure.
So one of the nice things about R&R is
it let's students go at their own pace,
and gives them control over
what they're learning, and
then what they do with
what they're learning.
Because they're simply reflecting on it,
and maybe they hate the article,
maybe they love the article, maybe they
want to share it, maybe they don't.
But either way they have
the power to do all these things.
And that actually is a huge part of
learning is having the power to control
what you're learning and
how you're learning and
what you're going to do
with what you've learned.
And so any kind of tool that gives
students that kind of power is
obviously a good way to go.
>> Great.
Well, thank you so much for
talking to us.
>> Yeah.
Happy to be here.